hey everybody what's going on i just got
out of a media screening of james bond
no time to die here is my non-spoiler
review as a matter of fact when you go
into the movie theater there's a hashtag
no time for spoilers why because this
movie is a very different james bond
movie than what we have seen in the past
not gonna say anything else good bad or
otherwise but it is different and uh for
those of you who are gonna be watching
it very soon don't spoil it for anyone
please i mean this is of course daniel
craig's you know quote-unquote last
outing as james bond i think he was
phenomenal in this film i'll talk about
that in just a bit but yeah don't spoil
it for anyone okay so now let's talk
about
the runtime of this film two hours and
45 minutes it's a long james bond film i
think it's the longest if i'm not
mistaken but
i might be wrong on that but it's long
does it need to be 2 hours and 45
minutes no it could be shorter they
could cut some of the fat out and i
think it would help out the storyline a
little bit more film by the way if you
haven't seen spectre in a few years
please watch spectre before you go into
this if you've forgotten some of the
aspects of that story because it relies
heavily on spectre for the first half of
the film and then it goes on to its own
journey after that but yeah sort of to
refresh your memory it would help let's
get into the overall story of this this
has a lot of twists and turns from the
very beginning you think you know where
it's going to go and it doesn't go that
way and i like that about bond films or
i like that about films in general i
like not knowing where the characters
are going to go of course it's james
bond so you know there's gonna be
certain aspects of bond that are going
to be quintessential james bond but
they've done a good job keeping you on
your toes for the two hours and 45
minutes that you're in the theater now
one of my big concerns about this film
was this going to be the woke james bond
and the answer is no it's not i don't
know why the marketing team at universal
pictures thinks that talking about bond
the post me to era and kerry fukanaga
doing an interview with a hollywood
reporter talking about how sean
connery's bond was you know you could
say he was raping women back then i
don't know why people are talking this
way as a matter of fact you're
alienating audiences from it because i
don't think anybody saw sean connery's
bond that way
i just thought it was really poor choice
of words in my personal opinion maybe he
thought the same and maybe wish he
probably could take it back so to be
honest with you i don't see any sort of
like you know the females are in the
driver's seat the guys sitting in the
back you know just sort of uh letting
them do their thing and james bond is
this weak guy you don't see that at all
this is james bond's film
this is his film from the beginning to
the end he is the star he is the driving
force yes there are some strong female
characters but they do fit into the film
i didn't get any sort of this you know
female power and we're going to do this
and all that kind of stuff i didn't get
anything in that in this film like that
at all as a matter of fact
it was very similar i mean at some
points i was like
i got a little bit of connery from
daniel craig's performance i got a
little bit of roger moore from daniel
craig's performance he's a little bit
cheeky he's a little seductive he's uh
he's the bond that us guys want to be
you know be like and women want to be
with so
for all those concerned about that do
not be it's just bad marketing angles
from the studio which they should not do
because it's not there in this film
let's talk about the overall story this
movie does remind me a little bit of the
dark knight rises in terms of its
storyline because it does rely heavily
on spectre like how the dark knight
rises sort of relied a bit on previous
films and it brings you into you know
then towards the end it kind of deals on
its own story and it's sort of like that
with this so the first part is spectre
then the second part deals with rami
malek's character he's not in the film
that much to be honest with you but he's
in it enough he's he's a great actor and
he has a great performances but
maybe if he was in the film a little bit
more there would be more of a
you feel more of that threat
that you know that big bad guy threat
that you would get out of these james
bond films in the past but because he's
not
and because his motivation seems a
little bit weaker than others in the
film because there's a few story lines
going on
you kind of uh
yeah it kind of falls flat in that
regard and that's where i think this
movie could have been fantastic it's
good but it could have been fantastic if
they would have fleshed out his
character's motivation a little bit more
that's all i'm going to say in that in
that regard
but let's talk about some of the uh the
actors in this okay let's say no now lea
sedona does come over from spectre and
her and james bond are in this
relationship and you really feel the
chemistry in this i mean inspector i was
a little bit like
i was a little bit hit miss on there on
their chemistry this film you really get
it these two are you feel the
relationship you feel
their passion for each other i mean it's
very different and i and i liked it a
lot i think these two are the driving
force of this film it's really about
these two in a lot of ways um and it's a
good thing because
i don't want to give away too much but
this was what really makes it a special
film and a lot and many aspects that we
haven't seen in other bond films is that
that attraction that chemistry and their
journey in this movie so let's talk
about lashanna lynch now her character a
lot of people were worried because in
the trades they were talking about her
being the new double 07. is she gonna
replace james bond is she gonna be the
you know the main the main spy in this
film and james bond just gonna be
sitting in the back no
it's not that way at all
yes she has the double 07 moniker it's
already been out there i'm not spoiling
anything for you but i will say that
it's a very interesting dynamic between
the two
but this is still james bond's film i
would say that of all the chara all the
main characters at least in the movie
her her character arc was probably the
least fleshed out which i was surprised
about because everybody's talking about
all the female characters gonna be
stronger and have a much more you know
fleshed out storyline hers not so much i
mean i was watching like through like
most of the film like she's kind of not
likeable in a lot of the movies she's
really not i mean towards the end a
little bit better but she's not the most
likable person maybe that's the
direction they wanted to go with her
very different from james bond in a way
but yeah it's kind of like that but she
did a great job in the role jeffrey
wright i love jeffrey wright
any movie jeffrey wright is in even
shaft i like him in it and he's
fantastic he's not in it a lot but where
he's in it
impactful and you know the chemistry
between him and daniel craig you know
these two probably just sit back and
having beers and and you know just shots
of whiskey and just enjoying themselves
offset because you can see these two are
really good friends i mean if they're
not man they've sold me because when
these two come on screen together just
it's so much fun you just want to be one
of the guys sitting there having a
conversation with them they're just
fantastic in it okay now let's talk
about ramy malik i did touch a little
bit about his character before he's
fantastic in the movie he's a really
good actor very talented he does bring
some of that quintessential bond bad guy
and his sort of his mannerisms and his
voice you know and of course he's got
the makeup on his face and he's a little
bit scarred up and you kind of you find
out a little bit why it's like that but
yeah his character was um
they could have done so much more with
his character but he ended up being very
so sort of two-dimensional
and it's it's a shame because he's such
a talented uh actor that they could have
done much more with him and i think
that's one of the
unfortunate aspects of this film so
let's talk about ray finds for a moment
he's really good in this as well he's
plays m and he gets a little bit more
screen time in this and it's not as
clear-cut of a role as you might think
he is really heavily involved in this
film in a way that uh
i think what they've done with the m
character you know what they did with
judy dench now they've done with ray
finds is they are really integral parts
of the storyline and i think
what you saw with judy dench how she was
so integral in skyfall it's sort of that
same thing with m here and no time to
die so it's really exciting to watch uh
don't want to give away too much but uh
it's not what you may think it is going
into it then we have christoph waltz who
is blowfield and he carries over from
spectre and he's not in the film that
much
but the moment he is in the film and the
scenes that he does have changed the
direction of the film dramatically
dramatically and it's always great to
see daniel craig and chris walls just
sort of go at it against each other
because it's like the batman versus
joker it's a mental mind game between
these two and it you have emotion you
have humor you have endearment you have
frustration you have all these things
that come into play carrie fuginaga did
a tremendous job with the scenes that i
saw it was
really really good so uh yeah he's
fantastic like always i love watching
christoph waltz i mean just adds this
sort of eeriness to every role that he
brings besides that we'll talk about the
cars aston martins are all in it range
rovers land rovers they're all in it it
is a car commercial it's a motorcycle
commercial a triumph as well if you like
those kind of things you're going to
love it
there are some gadgets in this film but
it's not overly done like the previous
bond films before daniel craig they are
there for a specific reason but it's not
overkill it's kind of nice it's a nod to
the older films but they don't overdo it
you know what i mean not every gadget
gets bound out of a situation which i
appreciate that's one thing i like about
the daniel craig era of the bond films
it was more him and some of his team
members but it's not about the gadgets
as much and that's one of the cool
things about this film but my final
thoughts on the film i enjoyed it yes
there are some misses in it it's a bit
bloated up with some of the um so many
characters and try to fit so many story
lines into it when it really is about
james bond and his journey i am going to
miss daniel craig he is effing
phenomenal in this film this is the best
i've seen daniel craig and bond
even better than casino royale in my
personal opinion he just knocked it out
of the park so much so when i walked out
of the theater i was a bit sad that i'm
not going to see daniel craig as bond
again um and you know
he's just so good in this guys he really
is i mean i hope he does what connery
did he know takes a little bit of a
hiatus and then comes back again i hope
he does because i don't know who's going
to replace daniel craig he's so good in
this role
in this film
even when the film
misses he's so strong in it that it
keeps the film going
man i'm gonna miss him ah
daniel craig was just so good and i'm
i'm sad he's not gonna be bond anymore i
really am man this is
i need a moment anyway those are my
thoughts on the film let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
any questions you have i'll try to
answer them and not spoil the movie for
you with that take care stay safe and
we'll chat to you very soon take care
[Music]
you